We want to bring you the latest
on a possible criminal indictment
of the former president.
Late this afternoon,
we learned the name of the witness
who met with Manhattan grand jury
and someone who knew the former president
very well.
CNN Senior
Justice Correspondent Evan Perez
joins us now.
So talk about the witness
and why they're relevant.
Well, Anderson,
the witness is David Pecker.
He was
he is the former chairman
of American Media,
the parent company of National Enquirer.
And he was key as part of this effort
to keep Stormy Daniels a story
from becoming public.
Back in 2016
in the days before the 2016 election.
He allegedly brokered the the payment
$130,000 hush money
money payment to Stormy Daniels
to try to make sure her story
didn't come out
and according to his version and version
from what we've heard
from from Michael Cohen
the former president's fixer.
He essentially got paid
he got paid from Michael Cohen
that hundred and $30,000
to make sure that that story
never came out.
The last known witness to appear
before the grand jury was a former
legal adviser Michael Cohen's
do we know how
Pecker fits into all of this?
I mean, it seems clearly that Pecker was
brought in to rebut
some of what that attorney had said.
Right. Exactly.
Bob Costello said that he appeared
as a witness
to undercut
the credibility
of Michael Cohen,
who is, of course,
the most important witness
in this investigation so far.
Anderson,
in the case of Pecker,
is believed
that he could be somebody
who could rebut
some of the testimony from Bob Costello.
Obviously,
he was involved
in helping broker
that payment to Stormy Daniels
and to make sure
that that story didn't
come out before the
before the 2016 election.
So presumably
he would be there to help
at least underscore and help
shore up
the version of events
that Michael Cohen has told.
And despite the fact, obviously,
that Michael Cohen
has his own credibility problems.
So what happens now?
Because this grand jury only meets
a couple of days
who were there right
there, said
they were scheduled to meet today.
And as far as we know,
there was no indictment returned today.
They are scheduled to meet again
on Wednesday.
They also
may be able to meet
on Thursday, Anderson.
What we don't know is when
this case might be wrapped up,
whether there is going to
be an indictment
and whether it's going to happen
any time soon.
We do know that, obviously,
the fact that Pecker,
who has appeared a couple of times
in this case,
you know, he's an important witness
because of his central role in it.
It does appear that the prosecutors
are nearly
at the end of their presentation
on this case Anderson.
Right. Evan Perez, appreciate it.
Perspective now
from CNN political commentator
Lucifer Griffin,
who served as White House
director of communications
for the former president.
And Jessica Roth,
a former federal prosecutor.
Jessica, clearly he was brought in.
I mean, Costello
was casting doubt on
Michael Cohen's testimony.
Michael Cohen had said this was
hush money, payment was paid in order
to not have some bad news come out
that could damage Trump to the election.
Costello saying
Well, Michael Cohen told me it
was, you know, Michael
Cohen's idea
and it was to avoid Melania Trump
being upset.
So this testimony,
I think, was very important to shore up
the credibility
of Michael Cohen's testimony
that the payments
were related to the campaign.
I mean,
that's the most significant testimony
that David Pecker has to offer.
Am I where he worked?
Entered into a non-prosecution agreement
with the federal government
several years ago
when they were initially investigating
Michael Cohen for these payments.
And in that non-prosecution agreement,
am I agreed that these were campaign
related expenditures.
So as part of that agreement is out,
does he have to show up to testify?
He has to be cooperative.
And so
presumably the federal government
is asking him to be cooperative
with other prosecutors as well.
I mean,
does an indictment I
mean, over the weekend, people,
you know, this rally Trump held
at Waco
were saying that
an indictment would actually spur them
on to support the former president.
Do you buy that?
I don't buy that necessarily.
I mean, listen,
he's the front runner at this point.
He's polling
above 40%,
significantly higher
than the next person behind him.
I think it's very likely at this juncture
he would get the nomination.
The elections far out.
But this is what matters in this moment
is Donald Trump
chose to use specific language
in the last couple of weeks
leading up to
this possible coming indictment
that has once again
calling for violence
and echoes the language
he used ahead of January six.
I know the man,
you know him decently well liked.
His intent there is extremely clear.
We know it from January six.
He's been clearer than ever, ever before
and it didn't materialize.
What that signals to me
is that he thought
that there was a base there
that was going to come out.
They were going to storm
New York, wherever it might be.
And people aren't turning out
because this is a Donald Trump grievance.
This is his wrongdoing
catching up with him.
It's not the same as lying
about the election being stolen
and people coming out to rally.
So I think it might be a sign
that in some ways he is weakened,
but at the same time, he's
still the frontrunner.
I just want to read something he said.
A reporter for NBC
asked him over the weekend
the rally
whether violence
would be potentially justifiable
if he were indicted.
And he responded, quote.
And this is so classic him.
I don't like violence
and I'm not for violence at all.
But a lot of people are upset.
And, you know, they rigged an election,
they stole an election.
They spied on my campaign.
They did many bad things.
Yeah.
The but's doing the heavy lifting there.
I mean, it's just it's
it's classic Donald Trump.
Take him at his word.
He's not being coy about what
he wants to happen,
but it's not materializing
because this is a mess of his own
making that's catching up with him.
And by the way,
you know, from unsolicited
and reaching out
that I get from Trump world,
they're nervous about this.
They really are.
They thought this was a case
that was dead up until a few months ago.
They thought they were going to get by.
And of all the investigations,
it was what
they were probably least worried about.
Now they're realizing
this is the one that's going to
likely come just in terms of the law.
Does it matter if, you know,
the former president
didn't want this news to come out
because he was annoyed, he was upset.
He was worried
Melania Trump would be upset.
He didn't want to embarrass his kids.
He I wouldn't say
he felt a sense of shame
because I don't think he feels shame.
Does it? Does that.
And he cared about the effect
in the election.
If there were other reasons
other than just the election,
does that make him immune?
If it's for the purpose of
of affecting the campaign,
that's what matters here.
And there's lots of there could be other
there can be other issues
involved as well. Yes.
But as long as the campaign was involved,
the question is, would it have been made?
But for the election,
that is with the legal test.
And so it does matter
if there were other reasons.
But there's really good evidence
that it was made because of the campaign.
Stormy Daniels had come forward before
and asked for payment
and he refused to pay her.
And it was only as things
were heating up
with the 2016 campaign,
and in particular,
right after the release of the Access
Hollywood tape,
which had done
considerable damage to his campaign,
that he decided now
was the time that he had to make sure
that she didn't come forward.
So I think there is very strong evidence
that this was a campaign
related expenditure
and that's also where Pecker comes in
so prominently
because he's already testified
that this was coordinated
with the Trump campaign
for the purpose of influencing
the election.
It was David Pecker
who was initially approached
by a representative
for for Stormy Daniels. Right.
And this is something that I mean,
as you state,
Trump could have dealt with sooner.
He waited, too.
And because of that,
it stepped into the legal murky area
of being a campaign finance violation.
I think it's
strains credulity
to claim
that he was doing it to protect his wife.
We that's not something
that I think we've seen
throughout the course of his public life.
I think it's not it's
I think we know what direction
this indictment is going to go.
I don't want to get ahead of it.
But I also want to caution
I don't think this is the strongest case
against Donald Trump
of the many pending investigations.
This is not
what's going
to keep him out of office again.
How difficult is this case
to actually put it in front of a jury?
It's going to be a very challenging case.
I mean, there are
a number of legal issues
that the district attorney's office
is going to have to overcome
with respect to the charge
that it seems that they are contemplating
related to the campaign
finance violation, which, of course,
would be
a matter
of federal law incorporated essentially
into a state prosecution,
which has not been done.
This is there's some precedent for it,
but not that actually been tested
all the way up through the courts.
In other words,
they have been pleased that
that reflected a similar charge,
but hasn't really been fully litigated.
And then as a factual matter,
they are going to be relying
on Michael Cohen.
And he is a problematic witness,
which is why it is so important
that he be corroborated
by other witnesses like David Pecker
and by the documents in the case
And also,
Kellyanne Conway,
I believe, from the campaign
also has testified before the grand jury,
who would be another important witness
to corroborate that this was coordinated
with the Trump campaign to scare off.
Appreciate it was fired.
Griffin, thanks so much.